yeah hello welcome to this video just
started a new game me a 15 minute game I
go to lately form just form for change
and he's going be five so yeah well not
f3 I won't play the Kings gambit even
for fun I don't really don't really
believe in anything else than I have
three him so we've got the Petrov very
often not the most exciting kind of
opening so hmm yeah what light should I
play I played this 93 line sometimes but
it really didn't lead to too much either
okay maybe try for something else get
the fog lights now yeah come on let's
let's play something else I recently had
a look at this fall from black of course
but down alright yeah this is some sight
line which is some it's interesting yeah
I think the only way to trying to refute
this ass night xe5 and then you can take
on reform or can castle yeah or this one
yeah right right right this is right hmm
so what should I do now I take Queenie
for probably but then I don't think that
I have some other moves okay probably I
need to take so
so it should be to you would take
probably and castles shouldn't be so bad
yeah I expect him to take unknown on c6
now the other Weiss is just a piece down
he could exchange on c3 first but he
needs to take on sistex not quite sure
how probably with a deep on and this is
what what I would strongly consider to
get the bishop developed on c8
immediately well I'd say not develop
this may be too strong word you can put
it out quickly right okay decided to
take first no not much choice and yeah
okay now this pawn is hanging but i
don't really am think i can i can cover
it it looks odd move that camera the
porn look look really unnatural like 23
or something yeah i probably am I'll
just leave it leave it there in term
play for compensation if he if he takes
it there is certainly some compensation
the rugby one who should be too okay
didn't dare to him to take it
understandably at them probably really a
it would have been a risky choice okay
so Bishop f3a probably played d5 and
this didn't really am lead to much
should I please see for baby to
anticipate d 5 so that I can take on d5
at some point yeah yeah thnkx e4 should
be it should be out should be fine I'd
rather play see for now before I place d
5 so that I now have options like taking
on Orion play C 5 i'm not sure that c5
looks looks a bit strange if i take on
ya 95 could be it could be a bit of a
nuisance that's ninety three years o an
idea but ok I can play Bishop to f3
maybe yeah probably this is a good idea
take a bishop f3 I have two bishops
after all and on f3 this Bishop should
be should be M should be fine and ok is
now I depends on Knight c3 is no option
how interesting ok well play wants to
play em bishop at 5pm attack attack the
porn understand mmm and pro-nazi 3 is
also not out of the picture interesting
yeah so what should i do I think I'm
thinking about rookie one rookie one FIF
as a possible idea so rookie one Bishop
f5 through v5 something like this what
take all rookie 59 years 27 yeah I can
also always play a bishop a3 first take
the rook and
when when like you have a tempo or
something I wait wait wait what about
Bishop e2 really we should be too and
ce4 there should be two Queen c3 prone
am okay okay yeah let's let's continue
with this move it shouldn't be bad rain
on Bishop f5 or take a look e5 should be
it should be a good move as basically
two pieces I hang at d5 and f5 should
should be fine
I'm sorry yeah what should you do a
making probably move like c6 down okay
you played this hmm so its root leaf
I've really bad and I don't see and
don't see what's wrong with rookie 5
attacking the f5 and Andy five what is
this plan I mean you can play in 93 or
something but this really terrible I
just play Queen d2 you should see two I
can take on d5 yeah I can take on d5
don't don't see it at the moment what we
should be five event and what what's
black doing none then don't get it can
just take here and I'm got an extra
piece right black resign yes yeah yeah
well this was a son dent but all of a
sudden yeah yeah well I proved at Bishop
f5 is not good here I think ok again we
can retreat yeah he doesn't need to give
give the peace with this can play Bishop
Bishop to e6 but the certainly wasn't
the idea I guess I'll just see six is
good here in this position yeah just c6
and yeah sort of anchoring this this
piece and yeah black should be all right
i mean it's got nice to nice pieces
so like should be you should be okay all
in all black comb-like must be fine yeah
maybe you can can play Bishop f5 even
here attacking yeah black must be fine I
mean I certainly didn't yeah find over
the board the correct way to to come
combat this line yeah I hope you enjoyed
this game anyway it was short yeah
thanks for watching